The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Andrew.
And this is basically--
we're continuing
our track on narrative
and writing for games.
On Wednesday we're switching
back over to production
and we'll be talking
with-- we'll have folks
from Blizzard to talk with us.
But for today, more narrative.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
We're going to talk about
writing for computer
games, or games in general.
I'm here with Heather
Albano and Laura
Baldwin, who have very different
experiences with writing.
And so I'm just going to
go ahead and dive right in,
and we'll just sort of see what
happens in this conversation.
And in a bit we're going
to start opening up
to questions from
you folks, then
we'll sort of play
it by ear, and go on.
So I want to start with-- I
want you to go ahead and answer
first, Heather.
What was your path towards
getting into writing
for computer-- for games?
Not for computer, just games?
HEATHER ALBANO: I usually tell
people I got into it sideways.
So my freshman year in college--
my first week of my freshman
year in college I looked
out the dorm window
and there were people with
boffer swords out in the quad.
And my new best friend
and I looked at each other
and said, I'll go check it
out, if you come with me.
And so I got involved
playing with a LARP,
and-- Live Action
Role Playing a game.
And then I got involved
writing for it.
And I did that as a hobby
for a number of years,
through college and
into the real world.
And in 2009 I lost
my job in marketing.
It was the year that
everybody lost their job.
And Adam Morse, whom
I knew from the LARP,
called me and said he was
founding a games company.
This is Choice of Games, which
possibly you've heard of.
They've been pretty well
in the four years since.
At the time it was a lark.
And he said, do you
want to write for us?
They never turn into anything.
And I said, yeah.
Why not?
So it started me on a
really amazing adventure
of-- started writing for
them, and now I do freelance
for other people as well.
And here I am.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Cool.
LAURA BALDWIN: Mine, actually,
is not so dissimilar.
I went to college and got
involved in the MIT Assassins
Guild, which hopefully
some of you have heard of,
which is another LARP, and
started writing for them.
I did sit-down games.
Then I went to grad school,
got a degree in immunology,
and decided I didn't
want to be a biologist.
Which is much like
you, losing your job.
HEATHER ALBANO:
Yep, [INAUDIBLE].
LAURA BALDWIN: And I got a
half-time job working with MIT,
because they only had half
of a head count in the thing
that I was doing, and
my other half-time
job was a friend of mine who
I had written some Assassin
games with and had done
some sit-downing with.
Had, at a point in the past,
founded a computer game
company, or been part of
creating a computer game
company-- Looking Glass, I
think it was Studios firsts--
And said, well, I
know that you know
how to write things, and
know things about games
and can work with
well with others.
So do you want to
come and work for us?
And since I wanted to keep
my job with the health care
I worked half-time for
them and half-time for MIT,
and did that for
a number of years
until Looking Glass
ended up going bankrupt,
and now I just work for MIT.
And still do
sit-downs and stuff.
But yeah, it does
seem to be about-- you
get into games
first and then you
have connections
with other people
and they get you
into game companies.
HEATHER ALBANO:
Networking works,
is the moral of the story.
ANDREW GRANT: It really does.
LAURA BALDWIN: Meet each other.
ANDREW GRANT: You
never know later.
Everyone you meet
today might be helpful.
Yeah.
So you've both done a fair
bit of writing for games.
Have you been writing
outside of games at all?
HEATHER ALBANO: Do you want
to take it first this time?
LAURA BALDWIN: So I work
in customer support now,
and that involves a lot of
writing email back to people.
That has trained me to be
concise and clear and friendly
in writing.
It's a little bit related,
but that's about it.
HEATHER ALBANO: OK.
In contrast, I do a lot of
non-game fiction writing.
My dream job for years was
to be able to write novels,
and it's actually less
so as I've had success
in writing for games, which
is fulfilling in its own way
and pays a lot better.
But I've sold some short fiction
and some poetry to magazines.
I've self-published two novels.
And that's sort of on the hobby
side of my life these days.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
We'll come back to that
in a little bit, I think.
So I want to talk about
what kinds of games
you've worked on, and
so what kind of writing
that you've done has
appeared in those games?
And feel free to name names and
whatnot of what you worked on.
Why don't head, Heather?
HEATHER ALBANO: So my
professional game writing
divides into three
categories pretty neatly.
I've done most of it
for Choice of Games,
which does multiple choice
text-based games of the Choose
Your Path variety.
So, kind of like the old Choose
Your Own Adventure books,
if you're familiar with those,
although better-written,
if I say it myself.
So that's all text, right?
All text all the time.
I was lead writer on
Codename Cygnus two years
ago now, which is an
interactive radio drama, which
is sort of the same idea in
that it is all word-based,
but obviously the interface
is very different.
And I have done some work
for paper-and-pencil RPGs.
TimeWatch by Kevin Kulp
is coming out next year
and I've got some work in that.
ANDREW GRANT: There's
a small world again.
OK.
I know Kevin Kulp.
HEATHER ALBANO: I
figured you did.
Looking Glass, right?
Wasn't he-- no?
OK.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
His wife worked for Looking
Glass, and et cetera.
So talk about
interactive radio show.
How does that work?
HEATHER ALBANO: So you
play it off your iPod,
and I think now your Android.
It talks to you and at the--
it narrates what's going on.
You play a spy in a
James Bond kind of world.
And so it tells you the
circumstance you're in
and then asks you if you want
to do this or that in response,
and you say the word.
The voice recognition
is pretty good,
but it's not
super-sophisticated.
It wasn't designed to be.
So you don't get to talk
back to it in a natural way,
you have to save the-- it's
a little bit better than,
pick a or pick b, but
you have to say the words
that it gives you.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
So you can say, shoot gun,
not for a villain or whatever.
HEATHER ALBANO: Exactly.
Not, I draw the gun and
duck behind the-- no.
I shoot the gun.
But yeah.
So other than that, it's
mostly multiple choice.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
So the behind-the-scene
mechanics
are very similar to the
multiple choice text adventure,
but it's text that's going
to be heard instead of read.
HEATHER ALBANO: Exactly.
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, all right.
Neat.
And you, Laura?
LAURA BALDWIN: What was
the original question?
ANDREW GRANT: The original
was what sorts of stuff
has-- what kinds of
games have you worked on
and how did your
stuff appear in there.
LAURA BALDWIN: So I was kind
of a-- since I was part-time
they didn't want to put me in
charge of any specific levels
or anything, so I was sort
of-- I did a lot of odd jobs.
I ended up writing the manual
for System Shock 2, which
was really exciting because
a lot of the time you have
to write the manual before the
game mechanics are sorted out.
So you would say
things like, this psi
power provides defense.
You really have no idea, sorry.
And then in Thief
and Thief II I did
a lot of sort of
like random books
that are scattered around,
or dialogue that characters
would say to each other.
There wasn't much that
characters said to each other.
And then the guards and so on
you're trying to sneak around,
and the guards are
basically walking
around being emitters
of what they think
is going on right
now which, you know,
if you're really
sneaky they're like,
I have no idea
anything is going on.
I am bored.
I see nothing.
I hear nothing.
But you know, if you let
them-- if they see you briefly
or hear you briefly,
then they sort of
have to admit their
state which is,
I am mildly suspicious
because I heard something
but I don't know what it was.
Or, I'm really
suspicious because I just
saw Thief going that way.
But you know, they're
not very bright AIs,
so they don't have a
lot of different states
that they can say.
They have a level of
suspicion and then a level
of what caused the suspicion.
And there's a big
matrix of that.
And then you don't
want your guards
to say the same thing
every single time,
so you have to have, like,
20 different things for each
of those categories.
And it gets kind of
tedious and difficult
to come up with 20
different ways to say,
I am mildly suspicious
because of a noise,
without sounding like you've
been coached to say that.
You know, how many natural
ways can you say that?
And then yeah-- I think
that's most of it.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Yeah, that's good.
And so let's jump
right into a little bit
here, the difference between
writing for stuff that people
are going to read versus stuff
that people are going to hear.
It sounds like you've
got a lot of experience
with that, with
long-form read words,
and you're talking
about guards that
are saying things out loud,
or also written books.
And those are very
different things,
I assume, in terms
of how the player's
going to appreciate them.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
So the thing that I
learned pretty quickly
about stuff that is said out
loud is that the players want
it to be really,
really short, which
makes it in particular
extra-hard because, you know,
"huh," or "what was that?"
You know, they want to have
about that much of interaction
with the guard that
they're hiding from,
and you have to convey all this
little settings because you
want to have people
know the difference
between a "huh" that's like,
"hm," or a "huh" that's like,
"huh!
I'm going to get you."
So there's also a lot of little
stage notes, you know? "Huh.
Angry."
But I ended up writing a lot
of little, short dialogues
for guards to be
talking to each other,
or other-- it was mostly
guards-- that you could
sneak by and hear,
and sometimes it
was to convey information
about where something was.
And sadly kind of the
first thing that we got
told after the playtesting was
that those are just too long.
Nobody wants to sit there for
three minutes and, you know,
hide in the shadows
listening to guards talk
to each other about something.
Especially not more than once.
And so really only one
of the conversations
that was more than
four lines survived
into the shipping game, which
is at the very beginning
of the first level.
And you can skip it.
It's the guards talking to
each other in the courtyard
about going to bear
bits, and you can go
and you can listen to them.
And it tells you a little
bit about the world.
Or you can just, you know,
sneak around and go back
to the secret entrance.
And so if you're playing
the game for the second time
you do not have to
listen to all of it.
ANDREW GRANT: So is there
a lot of conversation
left on the cutting room
floor, as it were then?
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Because it
wasn't until playtest that you
realized that it was too long.
LAURA BALDWIN: I think-- I
guess it must have been recorded
because most of our guards were
being voiced by programmers,
at least early on.
I think we definitely kept
Dan Thron as the stupid guard.
He became very popular.
ANDREW GRANT: He's got
a very expressive voice.
So I imagine your form
of fiction, Heather,
is a little bit different
because it's a longer form
to begin with, so you expect
a little bit more patience
on the part of your players.
HEATHER ALBANO: Yep.
And also all they've
got is the words.
The words are-- the
dialogue in the radio drama,
for instance-- the dialogue
isn't a distraction
from the mechanic.
The dialogue is the mechanic.
It's all they got to react to.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
You don't want to have--
they're not going to be saying,
oh, I want to fast
forward through all this,
because why would
they be playing?
HEATHER ALBANO: Right.
Exactly.
All they're doing is listening
to other voice actors,
you know, putting
together a drama
and then they're responding
to it, interacting with it.
The difference between--
there is a difference
between writing dialogue
that will be read
and writing dialogue
that will be spoken.
In the Choice of Games we
have a lot more freedom.
We have a lot
more-- we have a lot
of things that
aren't the dialogue.
You can put in a tag that
says, "hey, he said angrily."
Right?
Or you can say that he said
it while folding his arms
or whatever, that gives the
reader a clue as to what
they're dealing with.
When you're writing a
radio drama all you've got
is the dialogue and the
stage queues for the actors.
I got a lot better at
writing dialogue very,
very, very fast
out of necessity,
working for that project.
People who write
traditional fiction
will tell you that there
shouldn't be a difference.
You should always be writing
dialogue that doesn't
need the prose around it.
You should always be able to
get the character's personality
and how they're reacting
to the particular situation
just from their word choice,
which is a great gold standard.
There are some writers
who do that very well.
Dorothy Sayers, who wrote
a series of mysteries
back in the earlier
part of the century--
in the early part of the 1900s--
does this very, very, very
well.
You can read-- she's got--
there's pages and pages where
it's just open
quotes, close quotes
dialogue between two
characters and you never
lose track of who's saying what
because the personalities are
so very different.
ANDREW GRANT: So very clear.
HEATHER ALBANO:
Very, very clear.
Most of the rest of
us aren't that good.
That's really the gold standard.
But when you've only got
dialogue to work with,
you have to get that good.
It forces you to think
very hard about what
the different
characters are like.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure, sure.
I imagine the stage
direction helps a little bit.
So you want to get
across he said angrily,
but we can tell the
actor to do that.
HEATHER ALBANO: Exactly.
Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: And then,
of course, you probably
want to pick actors with
different sounding voices
to help it along a little
bit, and that sort of thing.
HEATHER ALBANO: Yep.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
HEATHER ALBANO: That's more on
the production end, but yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
Sure.
So one of things that a friend
of mine was talking about
was, he was adapting
a Shakespearean play
for a comic book form,
which is very cool.
But when he did that he
said he had to take out
about half the text of the
play because in the play
most of the information appeared
twice, because the listener was
hearing the play and you don't,
in real time, understand it.
For a radio play do you give
people redundant information
or do you just rely on them
paying really intense attention
to it?
HEATHER ALBANO: That's
an interesting question.
I think I would probably have
to go back over the script
to answer that for real.
My recollection is that we
did a little bit of repetition
to make sure that
any time the player
was making a choice they
knew the context they
were making the choice in.
So if there had been some
dialogue they couldn't respond
to they might get like a summary
from character number three.
"It looks like John
wants to do this,
but Mary wants to do this.
What do you think, agent?
What should we do?"
LAURA BALDWIN: Do you
have a Go Back button
so you can hear stuff again?
HEATHER ALBANO: Not in the
current implementation,
as far as I know.
ANDREW GRANT: But it sounds
like you could almost
play this game without
touching anything, is the idea.
HEATHER ALBANO:
That's the idea, yeah.
You can-- it does
come with a button
that you can choose
visually if you like,
but the idea was that you should
be able to play it in your car.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
HEATHER ALBANO: So yeah.
But of course we weren't dealing
with Shakespeare, either.
So it wasn't that
level of complexity.
ANDREW GRANT: Well, and the
poetry must complement it.
LAURA BALDWIN: Like,
in role playing games
where they have a
lot of voice-overs
and they have subtitles, I
usually turn the subtitles
on, just in case.
Like, sometimes I
miss a word or two
and I'm like, I can't go back.
It's a conversation
tree, you know?
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
HEATHER ALBANO: Right.
Yes.
ANDREW GRANT: That's
kind of interesting too,
because a lot of the
sit-down role playing games
that I've been in, a lot of
times the gamemaster's very
patient with saying, wait,
what did that person say?
And if you missed it, will
help you figure it out.
But in this meeting you're
talking about, no, there's
not a lot of help.
If you missed it, you missed it.
And part of the
game is, in fact,
comprehension the
first time through.
That's kind of neat.
So, all right.
So you've talked a little
bit about this already,
but all these
things are placing,
pretty much, a lot of
constraints on your writing.
You know, you're
talking about-- you
have to get across ideas
for dialogue alone.
And I think it's
kind of-- there's
a difference between-- there's
conversation that gives you
an idea of who the
characters are,
or just sort of some
filler, and there's
conversation which has got
vital information in it.
You might know before you
write that conversation what
that information is.
Does that change
how you approach
that writing,
knowing that you have
to stick some important
information in there?
Or do you now think
about it that way at all,
and I'm just off in the field?
HEATHER ALBANO: No, I've
got to think about that.
So I think every scene
has a particular point
you're driving towards.
If there are multiple
choices in a scene--
I'm thinking now
Choice Of as well as
Cygnus-- then every choice has a
particular piece of information
that you're needing to get
across so the player can
make the choice.
It's not quite a constraint
in bad way, though.
It's more of-- I don't know.
It's a more positive
word than that.
I feel like I've actually
had the good fortune
to be remarkably unconstrained
in the writing I've
done for games,
because so much of it
has been text-based
and dialogue-driven.
I think if you want to talk
about constraints, writing
for actual video games is the--
LAURA BALDWIN: So, I mean, Yeah.
The little grid of
"I'm suspicious"
is very constraining.
But I mean, to some
extent the constraints are
what tell you what you
have to write about.
I mean, I pretty much never
wake up in the morning and say,
"I am going to write a thing."
It's always, you know, what are
the things you have to write?
I think I read
somewhere that poets
said that the very
strict poem forms--
it's the pushing against
the boundaries that
are what make them interesting,
as opposed to prose
where you sort of
write whatever.
But it's more that sometimes the
constraints are kind of funny.
Like, for the cutscenes
the rule was you did them
in screenplay format.
And, you know, it's particular
margins, particular fonts
and capitalization
and everything.
And the rule of thumb
was one page per minute,
or one page per
30 seconds, or-- I
don't remember what
it was, but it was--
and so it was, OK, well,
we've got two minutes and 30
seconds budgeted
for the cutscene
so it can't be more
than five pages.
And you can't do the trick
of making the font smaller.
So there was a lot of
very strange text editing
where, you know,
someone would say things
and it was, like, a line plus a
word, and you can't have that.
That's taking up 10 seconds
or something with the one word
at the end-- which
it isn't, really--
but by the measurement,
you know, no.
It has to be-- so,
you know, I would--
sometimes you put in a
semicolon instead of a dash
because it's shorter.
And then, you
know, you would put
in the descriptions of
the scenes or the action
or whatever, which is like,
you know, "view of a study,
zoom in on the desk which has
an ink well," or whatever.
And you had to make those also
very short but descriptive
because you can't just
say, "study" and leave it
to the artist to
imagine what you mean.
And the reason that
the rules are like that
is because the more
description you
have in the set scene,
in the scene description,
the more time it's going to
take to show all of the things.
You know, if you have 15
different things on the desk
and you want to be
able to see them all,
you'll want to focus
on it for longer.
So it's kind of true that the
more lines you have describing
the scene, the longer it takes.
But it was a very
strange constraint
to write to, just because
it seemed so surreal.
ANDREW GRANT: So you're kind of
gaming-- you had a constraint
and you're kind of gamed the
constraint to fit on one line.
And that's actually
not at all surprising.
I mean, that happens with all
rule sets everywhere, right?
People game the system.
LAURA BALDWIN: And I'm sure
screenwriters have to do that,
too.
And they're probably--
like, if there
are screeners out there
they're probably like, oh,
yeah, use the short words.
HEATHER ALBANO:
And, interestingly,
there is an almost identical
constraint in Choice of Games,
where we only want so many
words on any given screen.
People are playing these on
a phone a lot of time, right?
So there's a rule of thumb
that I can no longer remember,
about how many
words you can have
before you should have a choice,
and how many words per screen.
Perhaps you might have two
screens before a choice,
but probably you shouldn't
do a lot of that.
You get the idea.
But so that leads to some
gaming, like with finding
a shorter word to say
a thing, but it also
forces you to think
about what you actually
need to say right now as
opposed to later, or never,
or, you know.
And what you said about,
if you need more words
to paint the scene it's
going to take longer,
that's definitely true
when it's prose, right?
If the player needs to know
about-- he's sitting at a desk
where there's an ink well and a
book of poetry and a something
else that's going to
be relevant later,
you have to describe them all
without knocking the player
over the head, necessarily.
LAURA BALDWIN: By the
way, there's three things.
HEATHER ALBANO: By the
way, there's an ink well.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
You just slip it in.
ANDREW GRANT: So you talk about
these constraints coming in.
Are these constraints
that were handed
to you by the rest of team?
And if so, is
there cases where--
how much creative controlled do
you have to sort of fight back
against that sometimes?
Or is it pretty much
written in stone?
Or how do you interact
with the team that way?
HEATHER ALBANO: Well,
when I was at Looking
Glass I was kind of the
odd jobs person, as I said.
So I would had really
no creative control,
but I wasn't looking for it.
I was happily doing
tasks that I was given.
Sometimes, I guess, I would
say-- you know, sometimes
you would get
feedback saying, so
you need to make these
things more this way,
and I would be
like, well, it isn't
possible to make them
more-suspicious-sounding
and still have them in the
not-suspicious category,
or, you know.
But it would be a conversation.
It was like, OK, the thing
that you're telling me to do
doesn't make sense, please
clarify, as opposed to,
I think the thing you're
telling me to do is wrong
and I want it different.
And--
ANDREW GRANT: So there
would be back and forth,
communication being
the key thing there.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
And, you know, often there
would be a level designer
who would say things
like, OK, I need
books for this, this, and this.
Or can you translate the books
that I've-- I have these pieces
of information.
Can you translate them
into Hammerspeak for me?
And so it was--
ANDREW GRANT:
What's Hammerspeak?
LAURA BALDWIN: Ah.
So the factions in Thief--
there were the Hammerites
who kind of spoke like
King James bibles,
and there were the trickster
minions, the Woodsies,
who spoke weirdly.
And that's kind of
the-- you know, they-- I
think Terri Brosius came up
with their dialect originally,
and it was, you know, "the
Woodsies sing in the treesies."
And, you know, it was
just a little weird.
ANDREW GRANT: A
little crazy, kind of.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
And it tended to be
not very grammatical
and there were a lot
of diminutives on it.
But it made them
all sound like they
were from the same
subculture, and I
think that that was useful.
Where did I start with this?
ANDREW GRANT: You
started with working
with a team, creative control.
If there's any-- how
do you manage that,
or was it frustrating
or any of that?
LAURA BALDWIN: I can't
do artists stuff,
and I wasn't very good
at the level des--
So I don't want the
creative control.
I want to do the
stuff I'm good at
and let the other people who are
going at stuff do their stuff.
That's--
HEATHER ALBANO: I
think that's certainly
the attitude I
would take if I were
working on a video game,
which I haven't done yet.
Maybe someday.
Because I have great
respect for people
who can do visual storytelling.
I have no artistic
ability myself.
So I would definitely
be pushing that off.
The Choice of Games-- I'm doing
a solo project the first time,
galloping towards the
end of a solo project.
The other ones I have done
have been co-authored,
and so there was-- the
first one certainly I
was kind of a junior
partner, learning.
And so the Choice of Broadsides
was the first game I worked on,
and when I joined the team
it was all storyboarded.
And so it was a
matter of, right,
well, I'm going to
learn how to do this,
so I'll take that scene
to start with, you know?
The second game, Choice of
Romance, Adam Strong-Morse
and I were definitely
colleagues.
And so there's a give
and take in a-- well,
any kind of partnership.
Any kind of creative
partnership, for sure,
where you have two people
with different opinions
on how to do x and y and z.
And, you know, we have a pretty
solid working relationship.
The one I'm doing solo has been
both freeing and terrifying
in that I have
creative control-- yay.
It's wonderful.
It's totally my story,
and that's phenomenal,
and it does mean,
however, that when
I don't know how to do something
there are times when I do kind
of wish I had a
co-author to say,
I actually don't have
any good ideas for this.
Can you--?
What I do have is a
very, very good editor.
And so we work in
pretty close partnership
where I can-- for
instance, last week--
write her an email after a
playtesting session saying,
I think we might
have to eliminate
this section completely.
If we do it we'll cause
these other problems,
but if we don't, I don't know
how to solve these problems.
Which do you think?
Leading to a two
hour conference call
where we came up with a third
option, which I would never
have come up with
by myself, which
meant we didn't have
to cut the scene
and we solved the
problems a different way.
ANDREW GRANT:
That's really cool.
HEATHER ALBANO: So
hooray for editors.
ANDREW GRANT: I really like
the fact that you mention that,
as you're playtesting your
work and it's not done.
You're playtesting your writing,
which I think is awesome.
And so that's a great example
of what we're talking about,
where playtesting
totally just told you
that something wasn't working.
Does that happen a lot?
HEATHER ALBANO: Unfortunately.
Well, I mean,
fortunately, right?
Because you'd much
rather have it
when it's still under
your control than when
it's out in the wild, right?
So the Codename Cygnus
thing I was the lead writer,
so I have a lot of influence,
a lot of control of the script,
right?
It was me and the Creative
Director, John Myers,
working together on it.
But John was in
charge of production,
so I actually wasn't involved
in the playtesting for that.
I would get notes that
were along the lines of,
this dialogue sequence
is running way long,
we need to cut it.
You get the idea.
The Choice of Game stuff I have
been much more in the trenches,
like with this game I'm working
on now, my solo project.
I'm buying dinner for friends
and sitting behind them
and watching them play it
because it's the only way I
can tell when they're confused.
You can ask people
to write you notes,
and they will, and
they mean well,
but they never
remember everything.
And so when you're sitting
there and somebody's taking
10 minutes to make a
choice you can ask,
so what are you
thinking right now?
And you can get an
idea of whether they
have no idea what's going
on, which was actually
where the problem in this most
recent-- that the player was
utterly confused and that
wasn't the first time I'd
gotten that feedback.
Although it was
the first time it
was utter confusion,
rather than mild confusion.
Or whether the player
is so engrossed
that they want to make sure
they do exactly the right thing,
which is a fine response.
And they can take 10 minutes
if that's what I need to do.
So yes, I've sort
of wandered away
from-- what was the
original question?
ANDREW GRANT: Playtest.
You found it.
You do it all the time.
In fact, you're
going out of your way
to do it on the solo project
which is mostly writing,
and you're still
playtesting a lot, which
I think is really fascinating.
You mentioned an
editor, you have
to imagine-- so you've
written books as well.
HEATHER ALBANO: Yes.
ANDREW GRANT: Do
you playtest books?
HEATHER ALBANO: Um, yeah.
I do, actually.
You don't call it that
in traditional fiction,
but absolutely.
You have drafts, and I belong to
the Cambridge fiction workshop.
LAURA BALDWIN: My husband
gets really grumpy
when I call him a
playtester instead of QA.
ANDREW GRANT: Who this?
Say that again?
LAURA BALDWIN: So
Jerry works in QA
and I often refer to
him as a playtester
and he's like, it's not
actually playtesting.
HEATHER ALBANO: Is he
QA-- not for games?
LAURA BALDWIN: Not
for games, yeah.
HEATHER ALBANO: OK.
All right.
That's hilarious then.
ANDREW GRANT: So Laura,
have you had experiences
with playtesting being
essential or showing
you stuff you didn't expect?
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
I mean, in general
for computer games
you have to have playtesting.
And I feel like there's actually
a new, modern version where
you don't playtest and
you ship broken games
and you just patch as you go,
but I don't approve of that.
ANDREW GRANT: That is
the new, modern version.
Yeah.
LAURA BALDWIN: Looking Glass
had in-house playtesting,
so you not only had sort
of the naive people saying,
oh, this is confusing, you
had people who were like,
OK, I know how is
this, this, and this,
and they would try to
do all of the things
and tell you which
ones were broken.
And that's a little bit
more for the programming
side and the level design side.
But I guess there was one thing
that came up pretty early,
was the head designer thought
that it would be really cool
if there was sort
of a thieves can't.
And so all of the internal stuff
that the Garret character would
be saying to himself-- and
sometimes the guards might
be saying-- they
would use dialects.
They would say things like,
"eagled" instead of "saw"
or-- I forget what we
came up with for "heard."
And he had this idea of it
being very Clockwork Orange
where it has its own, you know,
internal language that you
can mostly figure out if
you're paying attention.
And so my first set of dialogue
stuff was full of this stuff,
and the playtesters
were like, we
have no idea what
they're saying.
This makes no sense.
They're saying random words
and it tells us nothing.
And so that all got cut
out, and pretty much
the only thing that got kept
was the word "taffer," which was
sort of the generic swear word.
You know, you would
say, "you taffer,
I saw you back there,"
because, you know,
we were trying for
a no-swearing game.
But sometimes you want
to have character sounds
like they're swearing so we
had that word and it stayed.
HEATHER ALBANO: That's awesome.
I find there's a difference
between testing and playtesting
though, too.
ANDREW GRANT: What's
the difference?
HEATHER ALBANO: Well,
so one is technical.
Does the game work?
Are their crashing bugs?
And we have certainly at Choice
Of, it's two different things.
There's the, can you
play to the end of it
without it crashing on you?
Good.
All right.
First level.
That's great.
Can you play through it with
it doing the variable hands off
between the scenes
correctly, or do you suddenly
find that you're married to this
person instead of that person?
I mean, problems like
this happen all the time.
So although my undergrad
degree is in English,
I did work in consumer
electronics, such
that I was working
with programmers.
I was in QA, in
fact, a long time ago
before I was in marketing.
And so thinking about it
in terms of the black box
testing of, are the
variables being passed,
are the flags being set,
are the typos in the English
on the screen,
everything capitalize?
And then there's the
playtesting which is,
are you delivering
the experience
you're trying to deliver?
Which you can only tell by
watching a human being play it.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
I like that you
split those two apart
because when we talk
about it in class
we often don't make
that distinction,
but I think it's an important
distinction that there's the,
does it do what we think
it does technically,
and does it do what we want it
to do emotionally or enjoyably
or whatever?
That's has a good distinction.
HEATHER ALBANO: In
consumer electronics
I worked for Bose Corporation.
They separated it into
verification and validation,
were the sub-parts of
the test department.
It was, did we build
the thing right,
and did we build
the right thing?
We thought that
was pretty clever.
ANDREW GRANT: Awesome.
I like that.
LAURA BALDWIN: I feel
like, from my experience,
it would be kind of more
programmer bugs versus design
bugs, do the variables
do the right thing?
Programmer bugs.
Does it crash?
Is it fun?
Design bugs.
HEATHER ALBANO: Yeah.
That's a great way
to think of it, yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
So I've just got one
more question for you
and then we'll turn it over if
anyone out there has questions.
But before I do that
I want to point out
that, while I did
sort of warn you
that I'd be asking
a little bit about,
have playtests been
useful for you,
I did not ask them to go on as
long and as enthusiastically
as they did about how
awesome playtesting has been.
HEATHER ALBANO:
Is this something
that you're trying to-- OK.
OK.
ANDREW GRANT: We say this a lot.
Playtest, playtest,
playtest, playtest.
No matter how much
you're playtesting,
you probably aren't
doing it enough.
Anyway, so the last
question I have kind of
comes back to something
you were talking about
how, when you did your first
project you had the storyboards
and you're like, oh, I'll take
on this part and another writer
might take on a different part.
Did you have any problems
getting the voices to match?
Presumably you've got different
authors, different writers
for different
sections, but you want
it to feel like it's
a coherent piece.
You obviously want to
write in a similar style
to the other writers.
HEATHER ALBANO: Did
we have a problem?
The answer is yes, but not like
in a funny-horrible way, in a,
this is one of the
challenges with-- Broadsides
was three people.
It was me, and Dan Fabulich,
and Adam Strong-Morse.
And so it was sort of
part of the cost of doing
business, of dividing the
work among three people,
was the, hey, this
guy has a different--
has speech patterns that imply
a different educational level
when one person a is writing
than when person B is writing.
Either is fine for a sailor
in the Napoleonic era,
but we should pick one.
Like, these were bugs
in the spreadsheet when
we were-- We were like, we
gotta fix that because so-and-so
sounds like he has
a split personality.
And there were sometimes issues
between-- like, that's a design
thing, as you were saying.
That's a flavor thing, right?
There were sometimes
issues with handoffs
on the technical sense,
but that's also--
somebody wasn't setting a
flag that someone else needed,
type of thing.
And that was in the spreadsheet.
I think that's just a
collaborative thing, you know?
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
HEATHER ALBANO: What it
means, interestingly,
is that having three writers
doesn't save you as much time
as you might think.
It is probably quicker
than having one,
but not three times
quicker because you
have the integration phase
that you don't otherwise have.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
I like how you put
that, because you all
have encountered the same
thing through code right now.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
I found that having, for any
given sort of tone thing,
having one person who is
the expert, or at least
that was their thing,
like Terri would tend
to do the pass on all the
Woodsies and, you know,
make sure they
seemed Woodsy enough.
And I would do the
pass on the Hammers
and make sure that people
hadn't confused thee and thou
and translate things, you
know, into King James.
I mean, it wasn't
even real King James.
It was sort of,
like, what people
think King James sounds like.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
HEATHER ALBANO: For Broadsides
we actually had-- Adam
was serving as Lead Writer.
It was-- so this is a secondary
world Horacio Hornblower, so
not the real Napoleonic war, but
the Napoleonic war, you know?
But so it was his idea and he
was the Hornblower fan, right?
So if there was a disagreement
about the right way
to name something or present
something or whatever,
Adam had final say because--
I read three of the books
really fast as I was getting
up to speed for the project,
and so did Dan, but
that's not the same thing
as being immersed in it, right?
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
HEATHER ALBANO: It was actually
harder when Adam and I were
working as complete
partners and we
were building our own
secondary world medieval
fantasy from the ground
up, because there
was no-- sometimes it's nice to
have a final arbiter as opposed
to having to come
to a resolution--
not necessarily fight
it out, but come
to an agreement with
everything under discussion.
ANDREW GRANT: It's
just faster when
you start to get to an impasse
if someone can say, nope.
We're going to go with A.
HEATHER ALBANO: OK.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Any questions from out there,
while we're here at the moment?
Please.
STUDENT: So,
something I think is
true about the
Choice of Games is
that, if you make choices at
the beginning of the story that,
like, carry over and possibly
have grand repercussions
on the three-hour
mark, or something
like that, how would you
actually playtest them?
So it seems like
playtests having
to deal with something
that happened
three hours ago without
having the playtest go on
for three hours--
HEATHER ALBANO: Ah, so--
ANDREW GRANT: Let me paraphrase
that, just for the microphones.
You're asking about,
you run a playtest that
would take a long, long
time to see the results,
but your playtester
isn't that patient.
So how do you work with that?
HEATHER ALBANO: Yeah.
Well, I actually
don't know how you
work with it in that
constraint, because the--
if you are the
author and you know
the game you can
self-playtest it such
that you skip ahead to
see how scene five feels
when you're married to, Grace
instead of to Diana, right?
But if you're playtesting--
playtesting for real-- Choice
by Gaslight, the
game that I hope
will ship early in the
winter, has about four hours
of gameplay.
And the only way I
have found to test
what it feels like for the
players to make the choices
and be in it is to sit behind
them for four hours, which
is why I buy them dinner,
because it's the very least I
can do.
And these are all informal.
These are all friends of mine.
ANDREW GRANT: Of course.
HEATHER ALBANO: So
I think there are
things that you can't shortcut.
You've just got to do
it if you want to know
what it's like for the player.
On the other hand, there
may be a better solution
to that that I just haven't
found yet, I don't know.
LAURA BALDWIN: I mean,
so for a larger company,
the answer is you pay them a
wage to do it for three hours.
I mean, it's their job.
And they do become faster at it,
like, if they were playtesting
Choice of Games
they would probably
be able to read pretty
quickly the things
that they've read before.
But--
HEATHER ALBANO: Absolutely.
When I say four
hours of gameplay,
that's the first time.
The first three or four
scenes are not substantively
different, no matter
what you pick.
I mean, there are
flavor text differences
but they're not meaningfully so.
So once you realize that,
then the second play through
is just, yeah, right, right,
right, right, right, OK.
Here's where it starts
getting interesting.
Now I'm going to slow
down and read again.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
And I think that's,
in large part,
actually why we encourage
shorter games in the class,
actually.
Partially because of scope
for your own development,
but also partially because
of that playtest problem.
HEATHER ALBANO: Speaking
as the author of some
of the longer and more
convoluted Choice of Games,
speaking also because the
company encourages people
to download the code
and make their own,
they have a Host
of Games program.
You shouldn't start with
long, convoluted anything.
You should start with--
seriously, seriously,
seriously, seriously start
with something short and simple
and prove that you've got
the language and you've got,
you know-- and then
branch out into things
that will take you forever
and lots of dinners
to properly test.
ANDREW GRANT: So what might be
a good sort of first project?
Like a conversation or
a one-page short story
that ends up being branching,
a lot more writing than that?
HEATHER ALBANO: So a
typical Choice of Game
is divided into
10-ish chapters which,
at least within the senior
staff we refer to as vignettes.
I don't know if that terminology
got to the website or not,
but we call them vignettes.
So writing a vignette,
which has-- I
forgot how many words
they're supposed to have.
And, you know, let's
say four or five choices
is a good way to get a handle on
how it all works on the rhythm,
on the technicalities.
And would go back to
what I said earlier,
which is when I joined
the company I picked
a vignette from the 10 that the
partners had already laid out.
They asked me
which one I wanted,
and I picked the courtship
scene in no small part
because there was a similar one
in the game that had shipped,
and I had something
I could work from.
So what are working towards?
It should be about this long.
ANDREW GRANT: Got it.
HEATHER ALBANO: It should
have about this many choices.
It should have
about this pacing.
OK.
All right.
So I can copy that.
Got it, got It.
All right.
Now I'll do something
totally different.
Now I can do a whole game.
You know, you get the--
ANDREW GRANT: So
you started kind
of-- that's actually
really interesting
because a lot of people doing
computer game development
start as mod-ers, you
know modify an existing
game or an existing
level, and you almost
start with, you know, you
mod the existing writing,
but of course replace
all the words.
HEATHER ALBANO: Hey, you know,
a lot of traditional fiction
writers start writing
fan-fic, you know?
I mean, it's a thing, right?
It means that you have a-- I'm
sorry, we're off in the weeds
now-- but fan-fic
in particularly
means that the
world-building is done,
the character voices are set.
What you need to--
LAURA BALDWIN: You
aim for a voice,
as opposed to make one up.
HEATHER ALBANO: Exactly.
And similarly, the
constraint of the world
are known, rather than things
you have to impose, right?
So what you have
to figure out is
a plot that works with this
world and these characters,
and I'd say it's just a plot.
And then once you've
got that down you
can grow into sort
of the other things.
ANDREW GRANT: That's a good
little way to do it, I think.
STUDENT: So, something that
Laura mentioned earlier
was the whole standing
around and listening to MPCs
talk for, you know, minutes.
And it seems to me that in
the Shock Games in particular,
the answer to that
would be audio logs.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yes.
STUDENT: A lot more pervasive
than just a shock series.
And I'm wondering
has that started
to become too much of a
crutch to sort of get around
this whole, we want to
do all this exposition
but we don't want to tie
people down to a location,
or do you find that there
is a very specific use
for that kind of [INAUDIBLE]?
LAURA BALDWIN: So I think that
Shock, in particular, it's
trying to be sort of
a role playing game
which at its hallmark has
dialogue trees and stuff,
except there's no people there.
And so it's replacing
dialogue trees
with little monologue trees.
And so it's both exposition
and also atmosphere setting.
So I think that actually-- I
thought that worked very well.
Shock 2 had a lot of
sort of cutscene--
in engine cutscenes where you
would be going down a corner
and there would be
a window and then
there would be
something that happens
on the other side of the window.
And that felt a little bit
more like the Thief listening
to people talk, because it
would be this scripted thing
to happen that you would
have to watch, or not watch,
and it would take
place whether or not
you were paying attention to it.
And then it always had to be
built so that you couldn't
interact with it
because you didn't want
it to be the case that
you saved the person who
was being killed, or whatever.
But yeah, the audio logs
felt like, I thought,
were a nicely atmospheric
way to do text stumps.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah, the question
was, is it overused now?
And I don't know-- I
imagine, just like any trick
you use in a game,
if everyone does it,
yeah, it'll be overused.
But in some games
it's the right tool.
In some games it's not.
STUDENT: Just
following up on that,
it seems to be a very similar
function to, say, written
books that you find around in a
game like Skyrim or something.
It's such a global thing
[INAUDIBLE] building it.
But because you hear it
as opposed to read it,
it's something that you can
do while doing other things,
you know?
You can go ahead and move
the garbage cans while you're
receiving all this information.
And I'm wondering, if
that diminishes its value,
because you don't really
have to pay attention to it
and you can just kind
of like be the pack rat
and collect all the
audio logs without really
caring about any of that.
Or is it more prevalent
because there's
no reason to avoid them?
It doesn't stop you
from getting around.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
I mean, I think that I would
listen to all the audio logs,
but-- what is the--
there are some games that
have had too many books.
I could not possibly read all
the books, and so I didn't.
So I think it's
almost more setting
the right number for any
particular player's enjoyment.
And I have no idea how to
pick what the right number is.
I mean, probably somebody read
all the books in Morrowind.
I did not.
ANDREW GRANT: It's
player-specifc too, I imagine.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Some players
will read none of them,
some players will
read all of them.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
But the question
of-- I don't know
if you even need,
want to try to say,
well, we don't want
to let the player not
care about the things.
I mean, if the players
don't want to care
that's their choice, I guess.
I mean, that's a totally
different thing, you know?
What if people are
playing your game wrong?
You know?
HEATHER ALBANO: Nothing
you can do about that once
it's out there, right?
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
You know, so there's
the question of,
should you be able to use
the mods to let you just
kill anything?
Is that playing it wrong?
Or does everyone get to pick
how they want to play it?
Is using cheat codes evil
or, you know, letting--
ANDREW GRANT: Helping
you enjoy it more?
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
STUDENT: Is there an analog
of concept art in writing?
Like, for example
you have a paragraph
that explains what a character
is that's not in the game?
HEATHER ALBANO: Yes.
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
STUDENT: How often are you
responsible for that as well?
LAURA BALDWIN: So I guess
that's why we design documents.
And those are traditionally
not as well kept
up as they should be.
So they often describe
the state of the game
as it was three months ago.
ANDREW GRANT: [INAUDIBLE].
LAURA BALDWIN: Those
tend to be written more
by the higher-level
people than I ever was.
So there would be the
overall design document.
Here is what we want
the game to be like.
Here's what we want
this level to be like.
But that is a good way of
being sort of a tone reference
or a gameplay-- here are the
things we were aiming for,
and you can always go
back and look at that.
HEATHER ALBANO:
Specifically character.
You said concept art, so
were you thinking characters
or were you thinking overall?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
talked about concept art
being partly to explain to
the artists what they're
going to do, partly just
to inspire the team,
which I thought was
an interesting idea.
HEATHER ALBANO: Right.
OK.
I see that.
So the games I've worked on--
all the games I've worked on
actually-- except
for the RPG where
I was in the
world-building part of it--
have had character bibles
separate from other design
documents.
So there's the design documents
that say Choice of Broadsides
will have 10 vignettes and this
is the one where you capture
a prize ship, and here
are the five main choices,
and here's the
one where you have
the evil lieutenant over you and
here are the five main choices.
And so there was that, and
those do fall out of date
very quickly because
once you're in the code,
you realize you want
to do different things.
LAURA BALDWIN: And nobody
likes documentation.
HEATHER ALBANO: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
LAURA BALDWIN: I'm in IT now.
It's still true.
HEATHER ALBANO: The
character bibles
though I have found to
be more inspiring, right?
And so you sit down and you
say that the-- you can do it
in a few lines, right?
That the backstory
of this character
is this and the things
they care about are this.
And I recently
learned a technique--
Richard Dansky from UberSoft
is a friend of a friend,
and boy, is he a very, very,
very skilled game writer.
And a technique he referred
to was-- oh dear, what was it?
It was interview
questions, right?
But the point is,
you answer them
in the voice of
the character, not
just what the character would
answer-- their favorite--
their best friend is Susan.
But there's a difference between
a character who says, "oh, you
know, Bob, he's
always got my back,"
and, "I first met Susan
when we were in kindergarten
and we were friends all
through elementary school,
except for that time when we
had a fight in sixth grade
over the"-- and, like,
you know something
about both of the speakers
just from the way they answer.
LAURA BALDWIN: Most
design documents
are not necessarily inspiring.
But something that
is possibly more so
is the One Minute of Gameplay.
And it's sort of like
the little narration
of what you're doing as some
random moment in the game,
and why is it fun?
Because why is it fun
is kind of the thing
that you need to keep
focusing everyone on.
You know, the point
of the game is not
to show you the cool art,
or to make you listen
to my really cool dialogue.
It's to be fun.
And I think that if you can
write a One Minute of Gameplay
which is somewhat inspiring for
your designers and programmers,
then that's really good.
ANDREW GRANT: Questions?
Then I think I will follow
up with one last thing
and we may have already
used up an answer here,
but we'll all try it.
What can you think
of that you didn't
know when you started
trying to write for games
that kind of surprised you,
and now you would think
to yourself, yeah, I
didn't know that, I did not
expect that to be that way?
LAURA BALDWIN: I
think the screenplay
thing was the weirdest.
Just-- a screenplay has these
fonts and these margins and you
can't go over the--
ANDREW GRANT: [INAUDIBLE].
LAURA BALDWIN: Yeah.
I gather that you can
submit academic abstracts
and it has the same
sort of thing, you know,
no more than 800
characters or whatever.
But I think that
was the strangest.
Like, I just had-- that
was a very big surprise.
Most writing, I think,
feels more natural.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
HEATHER ALBANO: Screenplays
are pretty specific, yeah.
Personally speaking,
my biggest surprises
have all been the positive ones.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
HEATHER ALBANO: I thought
I wanted to write novels--
and I still think I probably
want to write novels--
but I didn't expect this to
be as artistically satisfying
as it has turned out to be.
Now, granted, I'm in a
pretty narrow writing field.
What I do is not typical.
What Laura's done is
more typical of writing
for the games industry.
Something that I
think surprises a lot
of people who have a background
in traditional fiction and then
transition into writing games--
because I've seen this a lot--
back in the LARP days we
used to call it the oops
I forgot to add the interactive
part where you have people
who are very, very, very skilled
at plots and at character arcs
and at story arcs and are
not accustomed to having
to leave room for the player
to interact with the world.
And this is, I think, a
problem you get specifically
when you have
somebody transitioning
from non-interactive fiction
to interactive fiction.
I think I was fortunate that
I made those mistakes very
early, when I was running
LARPs when I was in college,
and learned those lessons fast.
ANDREW GRANT: Right.
HEATHER ALBANO: It's sort
of-- at least at that time
doing Quest at
Wesleyan and it was
one of the typical
first-time Jam mistakes,
was putting too much
on their staff members,
their non-player
characters and not
giving enough room for
the players to, you know,
play the game and affect the
world and impact what happens.
You can't impact what
happens because we
have this scene for the end.
No.
It's not a play.
ANDREW GRANT: Right, right.
LAURA BALDWIN: I
have another answer.
ANDREW GRANT: OK, excellent.
It is awesome how cool
your writing sounds
when it is spoken by an actual
professional voice actor,
and I did not expect that.
ANDREW GRANT: As
opposed to programmers?
LAURA BALDWIN: Or by me, like
when I say it in my head.
And then, you know,
there was a little ritual
at the end of Thief where the
Dark God is doing this ritual
and I was like, well,
he's doing this thing,
he has to say something.
You always have to have
a poem for rituals.
So I wrote him a
poem to be saying.
And then the actor
for Constantine
came in and spoke it in his Dark
God voice, and it was awesome.
And then even better was when
it was translated into French
and spoken by the French
Dark God, and it still rhymed
and I was like, they translated
my doggerel into the doggerel
in French!
Oh my god!
That was neat.
ANDREW GRANT: All right.
Well, thank you both very
much for coming to share
your experiences with us.
HEATHER ALBANO:
You're very welcome.
Thank you for having me.
LAURA BALDWIN: Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW GRANT: I'll stand
here for your microphone.
PROFESSOR: Yep, thank you.
So, it's 2:08.
We're going to give you a few
more minutes to take a break.
They're going to be here.
How much time do y'all have?
Do you have any time after?
LAURA BALDWIN: Sure.
HEATHER ALBANO: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So, if you'd like
them to playtest your game,
just come on down, grab them,
bring them to your game.
If you'd like to ask me
questions personally,
please do just come on down.
The rest of the time is for you.
[STUDENTS CHATTERING]